[Applause]
thank you so much this is an incredible
honor especially to be included amongst
the other incredible student filmmakers
the idea for this film was sparked when
someone told me that dust from the
Sahara Desert blows across the ocean and
fertilizes the Amazon rainforest and so
without this dust the Amazon could not
exist and I thought that was one of the
most beautiful things I'd ever heard and
the more I delved into the dust the more
interconnectedness I discovered a web
including human health ecosystem health
and climate change as John Muir writes
when we try to pick out anything by
itself we find it hitched to everything
in the universe but we're in danger of
forgetting or just outright denying this
interconnectedness and yet no matter how
many walls we erect or distinctions we
make to divide ourselves from each other
and from the natural world our lives and
our faiths remain entwined
I hope films like this one can be a part
of the movement to act with this
interconnectedness in mind I'd like to
thank my friends and family for
supporting me through the making of this
film I'd like to thank my classmates
staff and instructors from the UC
Berkeley Graduate School of Journalism
including Spencer naka Socko
John ELLs Mike Shen Mark Shapiro and
Chris O'Day thank you to the people
featured in the film who had the courage
to be in front of the camera including
Rob and Wendy Purdy who shared their
personal story and the scientists and
doctors who shared their incredible work
- my co cinematographer Raphael Roy
who's here tonight and to the numerous
other crew and collaborators without
whom this film would not be possible you
know who you are and I'm so grateful to
you lastly thank you to the Academy for
recognizing the efforts of myself and my
team with this incredible honor thank
you